the stories of the Bible are some of the
most incredible tales in human
history Tales right and wrong good
versus
evil but how did these stories
originate I'm curious to know where
these cultural ripples
began
cuz regardless of your belief they're
important cuz they've shaped the lives
of billions over thousands of
[Music]
years my name is Albert Lynn and I look
at the world in a unique way it's
amazing I explore the ancient world from
space using 21st century technology to
strip away the Earth as never
before to expose Secrets buried for
centuries and reveal lost cities and
ancient
cataclysms this time it's the old
testament's most fearsome disaster movie
The Story Of Two Cities obliterated in a
hail of
Fire by the wrath of
God
[Applause]
[Music]
woo
hello I've come to Jordan in the Middle
East one of the most epic Landscapes on
[Music]
Earth this is the holy lands beneath my
feet just Rocky desert this is
incredible then out to the West you've
got Israel and then Egypt
South is Saudi Arabia East is Iran Iraq
and to the north it's
Syria where I
am smack dab in the
[Music]
middle I'm here to investigate one of
the most terrifying stories in the Bible
Sodom and
Gomorrah Two Cities supposedly wiped off
the face of the Earth by the wrath of
God so the Story begins with a man named
Abraham he goes with his nephew a guy
named lot you know looking for what they
believe they're God and promised them as
a
home problem was they split
up and lot makes a bad call when he
decides to settle on the fertile Plains
near a city called
Sodom at war with its neighbor
[Applause]
and condemned from
[Music]
above that is when things get
hot lot is warned that God is going to
destroy the town and they have to flee
without looking
back and he does just in the nick of
time with his
family as fire and brimstone be been
raining down destroying everything alive
even the
vegetation Lot's wife just can't help
but look back one last
time and because of it she's
instantaneously turned into a pillar of
salt as for the cities they were utterly
destroyed
this is like the mother of all disaster
movies and it plays into our most basic
fears an apocalypse that could wipe us
all out hurricanes floods earthquakes I
mean these are fears that still exist
today but was it just a story you know a
tale of
morality or could it actually have been
based on events that really took
place
so my first mission can I find any trace
of an ancient city somewhere this could
have
happened but look where I
am and now again from
space the whole region is a scorching
desert there's very little here except
sand and Ro
fck you know with so few traces it's
hard to understand how cities even
existed
here how could they exist in such a vast
arid
desert so where should I start to look
well there is a hint the ancient word
for
Sodom the biggest clue comes from from
the word sidam which in Hebrew means a
Salt Lake so naturally most scholars
believe it's somewhere in the plains
near the Dead
Sea it's a rugged drive across the
desert but eventually I come to this
vast Inland Lake the Dead
[Music]
Sea one of the most spectacular bodies
of water in the
world but it doesn't look like the
fertile Oasis described in the
[Applause]
story it's not sand lining this beach
it's
salt this is the Dead
Sea you know it's almost 10 times
saltier than the
ocean and I'm actually standing on the
lowest point on Earth it's one of the
hottest
too seems impossible to survive
here why would anybody settle in the
driest and saltiest place on
Earth well according to
archaeologists there may be a clue 80 Mi
[Music]
South
look at
that I've never
seen
anything anything in my life like
this this is
Petra an ancient city carved into Solid
Rock in the middle of the
desert
somebody somebody thousands of years ago
just dreamed this up in their
head and then chipped away at the stone
until it emerged look at these towering
columns here and the perfect
[Music]
lines I've seen pictures of since I was
a kid I've seen in in books in
movies standing at the
steps of the great treasury of
Petra
[Music]
it's magical by
night but by day it's something
else the scale of the place takes your
breath
away
Petra's buildings are a show of wealth
and while they're built around the time
of Christ they're the Pinnacle of a
success that started thousands of years
earlier at around the same time that
Sodom and Gomorrah may have
existed but the most amazing thing about
this place is not its Splendor it's
this
just look at this channel this is a huge
vertical irrigation system taking water
that's landing on the plateau above from
rain falling down through these grooves
and then channeling down towards the
city below essentially creating an
engineered
Oasis
unbelievable the people here were
Experts of C capturing water from the
plateaus
above diverting it into a network of
channels that fed into underground
systems
man look at
this and this is the kind of thing that
would allow entire city to
survive this is basically the bank for
life they figured out how to do the
plaster walls and keep the water in even
today there's water in here it's
incredible it's a technology that's
worked so simply and so well for so
long and it's got great
Acoustics it's like a big Music Box in
here you know actually this is what they
would have heard working down here
thousands of years ago you could imagine
it's like Hey Joe
have me the
scraper saving every precious drop
spelled
survival but the question remains why go
to all this trouble why did people want
to live here in the first
[Music]
place I'm in Petra meeting archaeologist
Katrina harmane who's showing me why
this vast City thrived in a harsh desert
turns out they had a strangle hold on
Priceless goods from across the
region the most extraordinary one is
asphalt asphalt the stuff that I see you
know on the roads today the the same
black tar stuff is yes indeed this is
how we visualize asphalt now this dark
you know material that you see in here
but at that time it was absolutely
something different
asphalt or tar is a semi-solid form of
petroleum which in ancient times meant
one thing money what would they use
asphalt for first medicine and the
second they used to sell it you know for
the Egyptians who used it in their
mumification
selling asphalt meant the people of
Petra could Rak in big bucks
fast but there was one source of asphalt
that everyone wanted to control
they had an asphal Lake there was a
large lumps of asphalt just floating on
top of what we know is the Dead Sea so
we had different nations fighting for it
for its
importance the biblical story is quite
interesting because it actually mentions
several Kings fought for the Asel which
could have been the kings of Sodom and
Gomorrah do you think that Sodom and
gamorra could have existed at the Dead
Sea trading the same asphalt indeed I
think that is quite possible
all very
promising but can I find any physical
evidence for this back at the Dead Sea
with the biblical texts locate Sodom and
[Music]
Gomorrah I'm setting up my tech to scour
the area can I find a link here between
the asphalt and the
cities okay check this out in these
scans taken from
space you see something really weird
just in this area right around the south
of the Dead
Sea and the whole area is just Pock
marked with these mysterious
holes heading down there I find a
strange landscape it looks like another
planet where the the Earth is cracked
and collapsed to form hundreds of giant
holes in the
ground look at these sink holes just
destruction the biblical Stories the
Genesis stories they describe battles
between the city of Sodom and the other
cities the men of Sodom when running
away fell into
tarpits not these ones but maybe ones
just like
this so the biblical story of tarpits
could have been kicked off by sink holes
filled with
asphalt Clear Connection to the trade I
heard about in
[Music]
Petra that's not all my satellites have
seen above the tarpits there's a local
water supply
F check this out on this side of the
Dead Sea You' got this
plateau and there's these Canyons that
look like they're cut right through
[Music]
it and where there's
Canyons there's
[Music]
water the season rains carve through the
plateau creating these Canyons you know
they're called Wades you get these
channels of fresh
water so just like
Petra the area seems to have had all the
ingredients needed for cities to
flourish now can I scan for any traces
of of the ruined cities
themselves to the naked eye it's just a
desert but when you look from space with
really high resolution satellite imagery
it turns out these Shores are speckled
with ancient ruins I mean check out this
one and this one right
here and fact there's at least five
southeast of the Dead
Sea and couldn't two of them be the SES
that inspired the story of Sadam and
gamorra I'm on the shores of the Dead
Sea on a mission to find the biblical
cities of Sodom and
Gomorrah my tech has revealed a whole
cluster of ancient
ruins can I narrow it
down I'm basically looking for a Bronze
Age settlement roughly 4,000 years
[Music]
old typically they were built on a
hill fortified by walls with the main
gate entering into some kind of Public
Square and these were features that were
described in the story of Sodom and
Gomorrah some of them here seem to match
the
description and one in particular a
settlement called
[Music]
numor it's a steep hike onto a strategic
position above the Dead
Sea and I'm meeting archaeologist Dr
Muhammad naar yeah so this is n P rocks
it's ancient I mean it's 5,000 years of
History Muhammad tells me the site was
abandoned suddenly around 2350 BC and it
has the same key City features that make
it a classic Bronze Age
City
dates GES are important to show that
your site is fortified and just keep
away from us
and Beyond them a square and
fortification walls fitting for a city
supposedly at war with its
neighbors at the far end of the
ruins something
intriguing so this is what we think is a
tower so this was once a massive Tower
yes what is interesting about this tower
that that it
collapsed in this spot here there were
three skeletons under the
collapse we think that was caused by an
earthquake that's so creepy I mean this
is where three people lost their lives
thousands and thousands of years ago yes
they were standing here at the wrong
[Music]
time compelling evidence but that's not
all you will notice Ash here and the
charcoal a this is
incredible the whole site is covered
with with Ash something burnt this whole
place down yes and this earthquake may
have been the same thing that started
the fire absolutely usually with
earthquakes you have fires massive fires
so interesting interesting
fire it certainly adds to the clues of
the
[Music]
story it's a tantalizing
idea an earthquake that Sparks an all
consuming
fire but what could cause them to
combine together so
catastrophically so I'm heading west
to a place that might help me find the
answer up above the Western shores of
the Dead Sea is an ancient Fortress
called
Mada it's really uh inaccessible up here
I mean it really makes sense that this
was a key strategic site in Jewish
history but I don't know like 74 ad
there was a battle where the Romans were
coming here and
this community of about a thousand
people ended up on the top of this
mountain holding up for almost 2
years the Romans built a ramp up the
back side of this entire mountain and by
the time they brought all their
battering rams all the way up to the top
of this
Cliff instead of subjecting themselves
being captured and enslaved by the
Romans they all killed
themselves
but I have not come here for the
Fortress but for
this
WOW beneath me the whole landscape that
would have surrounded Sodom and
gamor and it's only from up here that I
can see that I am on the brink of one of
the biggest
geological features on the
[Music]
planet feel like I'm standing on this
island in the sky with Cliffs just
towering up from up here you can see it
all you can see it's a giant giant rift
valley where the Earth's crust is just
pulling itself
apart and you can see it even better
from space
a 300M long tear in the Earth's crust
called the Jordan Rift
Valley turns out there are huge fault
lines running all the way along the Dead
Sea and where there are fault
lines there are
[Music]
earthquakes so that means that any City
out here around the Dead Sea it's
essentially lying on earthquake zone I
mean it's like they're on a taking time
bong so the next piece of the
puzzle is essentially were there ever
any earthquakes at the time in which
numero was
abandoned challenging question but there
may be a way to find
out for thousands of years water in the
Dead Sea has risen and then Fallen
meaning in places ancient sediments laid
down by flash floods onto the lake floor
are now high and
dry and in these layers there are clues
about ancient
earthquakes geologist revital Bookman
can read these layers like the rings of
a
tree this is weird what is a swirly
pattern shape up here how does that
happen there is a slope here and doing
an earthquake event at the sediment
shape you get the sliding of the
sediments toward the deeper part of the
lake that's an earthquake yeah this is
essentially an ancient siiz monometer
dating back tens of thousands of years
exactly if we date the sediment just on
top of it we will get the age of this
event so the cities that we've been
looking at date sometime to around 2600
to about
2350 BC do you find anything like this
around that time when you look at the
younger sediments um you can find
evidence for historical earthquakes from
that time yeah from that time that is
crazy I mean I feel like when I'm
looking at this thing I'm literally
touching the vibrations of an earthquake
you can feel it
shake that's the coolest thing I've ever
seen thank
[Music]
you impressive evidence but it's only
part of the story you know an earthquake
may have been
involved but the biblical text describes
something far more
terrifying a blaze of fire falling from
the
sky I'm on my way to see a strange
geological spectacle that could help
track down the events by behind the
story of Sodom and
Gomorrah on the east coast of the Dead
Sea is this incredible pillar of
rock the source of imagination and
Intrigue for centuries it's known as
Lot's
wife The Story Goes that Angels warned
lot and his family run away flee Don't
Look
Back well wife couldn't help but look
back one last time and in that moment
was turned into a pillar of
salt now obviously that's just a
metaphor that doesn't happen but there
might be something in that metaphor that
could tell us more about the catastrophe
itself could the pillar of salt in the
story help unlock the secret of fire and
brimstone 10 Mi away on the opposite
shore of the lake
is Mount
Sodom it takes its name from the same
Hebrew word for the Dead Sea sidom which
means Salt
Lake I'm meeting geologist amatz Agnon
Professor agnan that's Albert right yeah
thanks for meeting me thank you shall we
yes like we're on a different planet
almost yeah aots wants to show me an
intriguing link between salt and
fire this place is
incredible but what we're looking for
it's not on the mountain it's inside
[Music]
it
okay going in
I'm about to step into the
ledge once I go over this I'm just on
[Music]
air
wow it's so
beautiful it's like nothing about I've
ever seen
before I'm
dangling hundreds of feet off the
ground it's
nuts it looks so different up here yeah
the rock is completely
different it's just all this glassy kind
of Crystal stuff see if you can taste
it it's
salty yeah
it's a mass of salt this whole thing is
salt yeah the whole Mountain 10 km long
2 km wide 5 km high it's
incredible good job that was
unbelievable AZ believes mountains of
salt like this one could unlock the
mystery of catastrophic
fires salt and hydrocarbons go well
together it's typically hidden or
trapped under Sal under salt there's gas
under here there is gas there is oil
there's tar and
sulfur that's incredible and we're
sitting right on top of it yeah and uh
it sips up during
earthquakes so then an earthquake could
actually release these gases and they
could catch fire yes earthquakes
discharge electricity this could ignite
the gas this could form fire I mean that
sounds biblical to me yeah you didn't
have the science to explain it and all
of a sudden something like that happened
it sounds a lot like the stories that
we're reading about in the Old Testament
if you ask me if it's possible
yeah it's an incredible idea I'm
beginning to see how an earthquake could
cause something truly
cataclysmic like at num
miror a super blaze of explosions
inflamed by a lethal fuel mix from
underground explosions yes but I've got
images in my head of fire raining down
from the sky and something the story
refers to as Brimstone what could that
be
just down the road from Mount Sodom I'm
meeting geologist Addy torfstein
I'm trying to find anything that might
relate to the story of Sodom Gomorrah we
actually also find here suur have you
heard of sufur yeah of course the smelly
stuff have you heard of Brimstone the
fire Brimstone destruction that thing
exactly so Brimstone is actually sulur
and one of the few places we find
brimstone suur is actually here want to
see something cool yeah I'll show you
come what we're looking for is all
around us on these
Cliffs what is it look like small round
yellow nodules
suful here I can see
one grab
that ah smells like a stink
bomb this is brimstone huh found all
around us
here so let's collect more of these and
I'll show you something cool
okay you see this sulfur we collected
this Brimstone you can actually light it
up and burn it okay you can burn a
rock can see what look at that
blue and purple is bubbling and the rock
is literally melting away that is
unreal you can imagine that you saw this
happening you'd think it was something
Supernatural and actually quite nasty if
we breathe too much of it let's get
out oh
gross
so with this final piece of
evidence could it have played out like
this a city trading inflammable asshol
is struck by an
earthquake everything collapses even the
tower and those that survive face
something even
worse a raging fire as hidden gas
reserves erupt from from
underground while the inhabitants flee
explosions hurl down burning
sulfur it would have been hell on
Earth possibly but possibly not you know
I've seen evidence of ancient abandoned
cities burning sulfur exploding gases
earthquakes asphalt
I can buy into the idea that a series of
events with these elements could have
been combined to a single Collective
memory into an epic
story but what I haven't seen is
evidence of them all happening at once
in one place at one time you know an
apocalyptic moment should be a lot more
evidence right more than a Fallen Tower
and fragments of charcoal so could there
be something much bigger out there to
explain all
this
so I found some evidence in Sodom and
gomorra could have been sitting on a
pile of geological Dynamite set off by
an
earthquake but now I've heard a
completely new theory in a totally
different
area so I'm relocating 50 m away this
time to the north of the Dead Sea to see
something that I've been told is going
to completely blow me
away this is T Al
hamam some archaeologists believe that
this could be the ancient city of
Sodom you're going to come straight this
way way you're going to make a right
hand turn Steve Collins and his team
have been Excavating here for nearly 20
years and what they found is
astonishing this is in fact the largest
continuously occupied Bronze Age City in
the southern
Levant this gate complex is is pretty
impressive probably one of the biggest
gate complexes in the Bronze Age massive
Tower massive Tower Killing Zone right
in the
middle what makes you think that this
could have been the city of Sodom so the
reason is simply because uh the size of
the city the largest in the whole region
for the Bronze Age so it was a big city
then huh it's a very big
city this is way bigger than anything
I've seen so
far at almost 90 Acres it could have
housed over 40,000
people it's close to streams and and
springs of water and surrounded by flat
fertile plains as described in the
biblical
texts and it lies on two trade routes
one running north to
south and the other east to west it's a
pivotal position for a strategic trading
City on the hilltop there's the remains
of a palace
and inside it tantalizing evidence in
this area we found many many storage
jars it's carbonized of course burned
and the entire city everywhere we've
excavated we have this massive
destruction debris so whatever destroyed
the city also burned everything inside
of it something destroyed the city
things were burned inside it and then
you don't find any pieces of pottery
afterwards no there's a 700-year
occupational Gap so we have no pottery
from the period starting from about 1700
BC afterwards all the way down to about
1,000 BC there's no occupation at this
site so something happened at a massive
scale turning everything into this pile
of rubble in one moment right around
1700 and that's a good way to describe
it it's a pile of rubble is sort of a
mixture a
tumbling of everything this site the
destruction is absolutely the most
violent kind of thing I've ever
seen
this smack suspiciously of
catastrophe whatever it was it was way
more powerful than a
fire what could explain it melted mud
Steve's colleague Phil Sylvia has an
intriguing new
Theory this is a piece of mud brick this
is mud brick this is mud brick and it
feels kind of like pmus doesn't it you
can see all those little bubbles in it
and this was exposed to heat and it was
so hot the pottery itself has actually
been melted into glass glass probably at
an angle like this so that the melted
material started to drip off there's a
drip edge right here something flash
burn this material exactly to a
temperature somewhere in the range
hotter than the sun hotter than the Sun
by more than a factor of
four there are only two sources that can
generate that kind of temperature
profile that we know of one of course
would be an atomic bomb what's the other
one the other one is either a meteoritic
impact event or a an air burst
event you think this was a meteor blast
I'm personally convinced of
that but could Phil be
right could this place really have been
destroyed by a
meteor well just a few years ago there
was a meteor air burst CAU on tape right
over
Russia it's
incredible literally it's fire raining
down from
above the big question is is there some
evidence some clue to help me determine
whether or not a meteor could have
exploded over this region some 4,000
years
ago I'm investigating a new theory that
Sodom and gomorah were destroyed by a
meteor I've brought in my Tech Team to
scan the site for
Clues using highresolution drones we're
photographing the site from multiple
different angles so we can build a 3D
computer model perfect meanwhile Phil
Sylvia wants to show me something else
that supports his
theory this is about 400 lb worth of
Rock it was sitting on a dirt pedestal
and when the blast hit it got rolled off
of that pedestal and dumped on its side
you're saying that something moved this
massive Stone that's right doesn't move
[Music]
itself Phil believes the meteor exploded
Somewhere Over The Dead Sea creating a
blast powerful enough to move Solid
Rock the debris field was all pushed in
this direction and banked up against
this wall so your theory is that there
was a big explosion over there creating
a flash of fire hotter than the sun
blasting everything against these walls
and vaporizing everybody in the city all
at once
yes not only that but Phil's theory has
one final component that resonates with
the biblical
story when you have an air burst over
water it creates a tsunami effect and
that pushed a tremendous volume of water
across the full width of the valley
floor this whole area was taken offline
by this event and it became
uninhabitable because of the salt
poisoning of the
ground the theory explains every element
of the biblical
texts burning question is have the tech
team found anything to back it
up so Steve for the afternoon Patricia
has been flying a drone around
collecting photographs to create this
photogrametry model of the site show us
what you found yeah with photogrametry
what we can do is we can take loads and
loads of different pictures and then we
stitch all of those photographs together
and we can make a 3D model which I think
gives us a completely different
perspective so let's fly through
that this is your
site I was very interested in this area
the big circular area mhm to the left we
think this is a very large water feature
like a sstn and you can see the size of
it the feature doesn't really show very
well on here but when we actually look
at the 3D model that's interesting we've
got lots of different colors it's much
much more pronounced yeah wow look at
that we've been looking at the site for
for over a decade but looking at this
image and it's the first time I thought
of this but it it looks like an impact
Creator this the first time you thought
that that might be yeah I mean the way I
look at it I was thinking as you were as
you were moving in on it it looks like
you're on
Moon well which side is the actual side
where they this is the southwest side it
would have come from this direction the
Southwest good job Patricia
yeah who knows what it is but it's a
clue we need to excavate
that Steve's team will need to prove
this really is a
meteor but it does fit with their other
evidence here and offers a plausible
terrifying explanation for the
story a meteor blasts in from space at
Hypersonic
speed exploding over the Dead
Sea it blasts salt across Landscaping
rendering it infertile for
Generations a fragment lands right by
the
city vaporizing it to
Oblivion
you know the fear of Apocalypse it's in
all of us but very few stories deliver
it on this
scale one thing's for sure when I
started this journey I thought it was
just a tale of projected
morality and what I actually found was a
Showcase of some of the most incredible
geological phenomenon in a place where
the Earth crust is literally ripping
itself apart where the powers of
Destruction are so terrible that they
may have gone down as being the hand of
[Music]
God